and so the way that we're going to do
this is by saying well under the null
hypothesis there's really no difference
between the x's and the y's they all
have the same mean under the null
hypothesis so i'm just going to scramble
them i'm just going to shuffle them
together i'm going to permute them i'm
going to resample them and i'm going to
generate a t statistic on that shuffle
data i'm going to do that a huge number
of times
in order to
simulate the null distribution
and the idea here is that if i shuffle
the data i'm essentially guaranteeing
that the null distribution is correct
because even if there was a difference
once i've shuffled it though that
difference will go away or state it
another way under the null distribution
it doesn't matter whether we shuffled
our data it's all the same either way
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to compute a two-sample
t-statistic
on our data and then we're going to do
something a huge number of times where b
is a really big number like if you're
lazy then b might be 100 and if you are
a very energetic person or actually
maybe if you're a lazy person because
your code will run for a long time so
you'll have a long time to go get a
coffee well whatever your b might be
larger like 10 000
but bigger b is better so what you're
going to do is you're going to randomly
shuffle the observations
and then you're going to call the first
n sub x observations x 1 star through x
and x star and the remaining
observations are going to be y 1 star
through y and y star so all that you've
done so far is you took your x's and
your ys you put them in a basket you
shook up the basket you grabbed nx and
called them x stars you grabbed ny
called them y stars
and now you're going to compute a
two-sample t-statistic on the shuffled
data and you're going to call it t-star
where the little b is because this is
the little beef
time that we're going to do this
procedure
and then after we've done this capital b
times like 1 000 times we're going to
compute a p-value and the p-value is
just the fraction of the time
that the t-statistic on the shuffled
data exceeded an absolute value the
t-statistic on the real data
so what does this notation mean gareth
that one with the subscript
so this is just counts as a one a value
of one if this uh
quantity in the parentheses is true and
zero otherwise so it's just a so with
the summation here this is just counting
the number of times that's true yeah so
this the numerator is just the number of
simulated data sets or the number of uh
resample data sets reshuffle data sets
for which the test statistic exceeded
the test statistic that we got on our
real data and i'm dividing it by the
number of times i did this reshuffling
and the reason we have these absolute
values here is because we're computing a
a two-sided p-value where we're equally
interested
in um if the
means are unequal we're equally
interested and the x's mean being larger
than the wise mean versus the wise mean
being larger than the x's mean this is a
two-sided p-value if you only wanted a
one-sided p-value you could get rid of
those absolute values
and the concept here is that if the
re-sampled statistics are almost all
smaller than the observed t statistic
then we're pretty suspicious that the
null hypothesis is not true but if we
get quite a few re-sampled t statistics
that are just as large or even larger
than what we observed
then we're not so interested we we we're
no longer suspicious about that value
right
so here's what we get if we take some
gene expression data and we look at a
particular gene
where we have a control group and
treatment group
measured for this gene and for this
particular gene on the real data our
t-statistic is negative 2.09 that's the
blue line and in orange i'm showing you
the theoretical null distribution for
that t-statistic so that's an orange and
if i take this shuffling or resampling
approach in order to simulate the null
distribution i get the histogram shown
in yellow and indeed what i see here is
that the the yellow histogram so that
reshuffle distribution that i got for
the null distribution is pretty similar
to the theoretical normal distribution
shown in orange it doesn't really matter
much that i did reshuffling and in fact
here the theoretical p-value if i use
that theoretical normal 0-1 distribution
as my null distribution for the
t-statistic is 0.041 my resampling
p-value is 0.042
so in this particular example this was a
big load of nothing and the reason it
was a big load of nothing again is
because the theoretical null
distribution actually was pretty close
to my reshuffled null distribution
anyway so it just didn't really matter
though it does add confidence that we
had the right answer
yeah there is something to be said for
just like using a resampling approach
when you can because like why not it
just feels a little like
like you've made fewer assumptions and
actually here is on the same dataset a
different gene and you can really see
now here's a gene where our results are
actually a bit different depending on
whether i use the theoretical null
distribution shown in orange versus the
reshuffled null distribution shown in
yellow as the yellow histogram
and we can see that actually um those
two distributions do look a bit
different our observed test statistic is
negative 0.5696
and my theoretical p-value resulting
from the theoretical null distribution
is 0.571 whereas the resampling p-value
is 0.673 so in this particular case both
p-values are large so this won't really
probably affect any conclusions that i
draw about the data or rather
conclusions that i draw from the data
but nonetheless we can see here that
sometimes a resampling approach can give
you result that is a bit different and
in general a resampling approach you're
like kind of trading off computational
time for
making slightly weaker assumptions
and the computer doesn't mind doing that
extra work so the computer doesn't mind
doing the extra work that's true
and it's always a good excuse to like go
get a long coffee while your computer is
running through those capital b equals
10 000 um
reshuffles
all right so when are resampling
approaches useful well they're they're
definitely useful if the theoretical
null distribution is unavailable so in
the case of a two sample t statistic if
you have a large sample size
this is just my opinion a different side
decision might disagree with me i feel
like if you're doing a two sample t
statistic
and your sample size is really really
large maybe you don't really need a
resampling approach but if your sample
size is smaller
then that's a really good reason you
might want a resampling approach for a
two-sample t-test because in that case
we actually don't know the theoretical
null distribution
or maybe there's a test statistic that
you're interested in or null hypothesis
you're testing for which you really just
don't know the theoretical null
distribution at all without making some
really strong assumptions
so one way to think about this is that
resampling approaches maybe we can just
say they're always useful because they
don't usually cost us very much
to do and
they can allow us to overcome some
hurdles associated with not knowing a
theoretical null distribution
so here we've talked about using
resampling to compute a p-value it turns
out you can also use a resampling
approach to control the fdr if you look
it up in the textbook actually we work
through that and we also work through it
in the r lab
so you can see how we can use resampling
to control fdr in the book um we're not
going to cover it today in this lecture
and then finally here we talked about a
two-sample t-test but you can develop
similar approaches for other test
statistics it just requires a bit of
thinking it's not usually like just a
command in r where you just like type it
in and then you get a p-value out you
need to think about like how would you
design a resampling approach based on
your particular null hypothesis and your
particular test statistic and it's not
always so clear how to do it a
two-sample t-statistic is kind of like a
very easy example but it can often be
trickier all right well that's it well
i'm looking forward to trying to do all
of this in the r lab next yes if there
are any if anything doesn't run it's
because we're using gareth's computer so
just
be warned can i make a joke about how
your computer is daniela doesn't like
pcs yeah it's i've never been seen with
a pc before this is hopefully we wanted
to make it clear that this is not who i
actually wanted to put an apple sticker
on this um but i did not have one with
me so i wasn't able to do that
dell would probably sue you as well all
right